[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the guy who always
gets a Joel in one and this video we're
breaking down everything we think could
be happening with the Last of Us Part
three the game is yet to be announced
but there are leaks and rumors out there
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down everything that we
think will be happening in the title
balls spoilers ahead including the
ending of part two so if you haven't
played that then I highly recommend you
turn off now please hit the Thumbs Up
Button if you enjoy the video and make
sure you subscribe for more Last of Us
videos on the show and game by the way
huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into The Last of Us Part three
A Part 2 actually contains some clues
about where things could be going at the
end of the game we follow Abby and Lev
as they make their own way away from
Seattle the pair are looking for the
fireflies and we discover that after the
events of part one that they pretty much
disbanded Ellie actually came across
some graffiti at one point calling them
liars and we learned that Abby ended up
having to join the wlf because they'd
Fallen apart however rumors had a reason
once more that they were out there in
the world and we joined the Paris they
came across an abandoned Firefly Outpost
packed with supplies in a radio after
speaking into it I heard back from one
of their members and we got this scene
hi Abby we got a clear signal on you
where in Santa Barbara are you calling
from
um 24 25 constants
uh we got a tip about a base but there's
no one here
we're looking for fireflies
I'm I'm a firefly
where were you stationed
I was part of the Salt Lake Outpost
[Music]
we ran that facility
Dr Jerry Anderson
he was my dad
how about that
we pulled everyone back from the
satellite stations and brought them back
here to home base how many of you are
there
200 strong now
with a few more every month
that one was right
you're about to get two more
how do we find you
get to Catalina Island
approach the large domes building an
Avalon
we'll find you
okay we'll see you soon over and out
I'm more into it good luck Abby from
Santa Barbara
over and out
now upon leaving this house Rattler's
arrived and they captured them both
because of this many have suspected that
the radio call was just a trap and that
they were finding out where they were so
that they could take them in Rattlers
are slavers and though we don't know
exactly what happened with the pair they
got really messed up when Ellie finally
called back up with Abby she found her
severely starved with her hair cut down
and bruises all over her body she was a
shell of her former self and though Ali
freed her and Lev she eventually ended
up buying with her after she was hit
with a PTSD flashback of Joel's death in
the end though she saw Revenge led to
nothing but loss and she let Abigail
which is when she and Lev sailed off
into places unknown now the reason that
I think the Firefly radio call was
legitimate is because after you complete
the game the menu screen changes this
shows you Catalina Island with about
next to a large Dome building Abby's
face model even made a joke out this
recently and Neil druckman confirmed on
the kind of funny podcast that this
shows they made it out there so I do
think that the radio call was legit it
and that third game could follow Abby as
she gets back in with the fireflies now
in Sequel games he often start off with
none of your upgrades and abilities from
the last one and doing this always was a
bit weird to me I remember the old God
of War games when a complete one and be
a complete G and then in the next one
they'd have to come up with some
convoluted reason as to why I no longer
had my amazing upgrades even though they
were continuing the same story however
Abby not only had her backpack taken
away but she also had this kicked
out of her so it makes sense as to why
she's having to start again from fresh
now as for Ali we last saw her returning
to The Farmhouse to find it abandoned
previously she'd lived there with Dina
but after she said she was going back
out there for happy Dina gave her an
ultimatum she said she'd take her and a
kid and this came true when she returned
home it was completely abandoned and
after realizing that she could no longer
Play the song she associated with Joel
she left the farm disheveled the
direction she went was towards Jackson
but we don't know what happened from
from that point onwards now small
thoughts are a few time on what I think
could end up happening but I do think
it's possible to bring things full
circle from the first game with the
fireflies still wanting to develop a
cure Abby was aware that Ali was immune
and though this could end up making the
fireflies go after her I think they'll
do something different Alien Part 2 made
it clear that she would have given her
life for the Cure and that she now feels
like she meant nothing because of what
Jill took away from her therefore the
third game could potentially culminate
with her deciding to go through with the
procedure once more unless it would end
her story and make her life mean
something in the grand scheme of things
and that's obviously some straight of
fan fiction there so if you have your
own thoughts and theories on what they
could do then make sure you comment
below anyway as for whether the game is
even being developed things haven't been
confirmed yet but there are several
leaks recently on the kind of funny
podcast Neil druckman said that Naughty
Dog were working on the next game and
that they denounce it when they were
ready beyond that he's been in full
Andrew Garfield mode whether he if we
look at things that he said since the
start of the air there are actually some
Clues it's in development now he told
The Hollywood Reporter that there was
more of a story to tell after the events
of the second game and then told the
script apart podcasts that the third
game script had been completed but he
did say it wasn't in development and
damage control was quickly followed up
with Naughty Dog releasing an official
statement who said that though the
script had been done they were working
on a mysterious title that they can't
tell us about yet so there are things in
play for the Last of Us Part 3 but it
might be a while before we see it
according to the leaks and rumors they
say it's in development but state that
it will likely release at the end of the
life cycle of the PlayStation 5 and
probably earlier in the release of six
The Last of Us games have always been
like this with part 1 releasing at the
end of the PlayStation 2's life cycle
and part 2 coming in towards the end of
the PlayStation 4. so it's likely going
to be a similar thing and it means that
naughty dog can maximize the software
and sell the game when the console is in
the most people's homes now when
discussing the show Neil said that they
don't really want to get into a Game of
Thrones situation where the series ends
about pacing the show and they don't
have Source material to work off of I
think that's fair enough as we all saw
what happened with the latter parts of
Game of Thrones and it's pointless if
you don't learn from the past and do
things the right way it's clear they
just want to avoid that and we know that
at the very least the party will be
adapted into Seasons two and three of
the show as potentially a two-year gap
between each season and this will be at
the very least six years before season 4
releases this would probably give them
enough time to develop the game but if
the script's completed then I don't see
why they can't start work on season 4.
they could even tie them in together and
druckman has said that the next game
will be paced like a TV show in an
episodic format I think that would work
really well with it being released
alongside the third game and we also
know that Naughty Dog are currently in
the middle of developing The Last of Us
factions as well this is the multiplayer
game but they've said it's as big as
their single player ones whether that
has store elements and all it is another
thing entirely that could be used as a
way to introduce characters that then
potentially pop up in the third game I
think it would be a really cool way to
handle things and hopefully we get
something along those lines in the
future with the franchise now in the
meantime obviously let me know your
thoughts on the game series and also the
show I'll of course keep you on the know
as more news comes out on it so make
sure you stay locked to the channel for
updates on the series in the game we are
running a competition right now and
giving away the Superman 4K box set of
three subscribers on the 15th of April
all you have to do to be when the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
we beat the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now so that's
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
Brighton of The Last of Us finale which
will be linked on screen right now got
loads of Easter eggs in it lots of
comparisons to the game so definitely
head over there right after this by the
way thanks for sticking through the
video I've been poor and I'll see you
next time take care peace